Salut la team mentalo !
Suite à la vidéo d'hier où j'étais avec Eli.
Où j'ai fait une addition très rapide.
J'ai décidé de vous faire un masterclass
pour que vous puissiez faire pareil :
Compter très rapidement les additions dans votre tête.
C'est une manière de compter que j'ai appris dans un livre quand j'étais petit
l'édition originale de ce livre s'appelle Miracle Math
et a été édité en 1966 par Harry Lorayne.
Le principe est simple, c'est une stratégie d’ascenseur.
Nous allons faire des allers-retours dans les chiffres
pour compter n'importe quelle addition très facilement
très simplement et sans erreur possible.
Imaginons que vous deviez additionner tous ces nombres ensemble.
Je sais que là vous pouvez le faire de tête
mais il faut que vous compreniez exactement la méthode de l'ascenseur.
Nous allons, quelle que soit l'addition
partir du chiffre en bas à gauche
pour ensuite remonter, et à chaque changement de colonne nous redescendrons
et si on doit rechanger de colonne, on remontera, etc.
Je prends le chiffre en bas à gauche dans ma tête.
Je fixe le 1.
1 + 3 = 4
+ 2 = 6
+ 1 = 7
Au changement de colonne
je colle le prochain chiffre à celui que j'ai en tête.
Donc j'ai 7 en tête, maintenant je vais penser à 73
puisque je colle mon 3 à mon 7.
Maintenant que j'ai 73 en tête
je descends en continuant mon addition.
73, 76, 77, 79.
Mon résultat est donc de 79.
L'exemple était facile, il n'y avait pas de retenue
pour que vous puissiez bien comprendre.
Mais qu'est ce qu'il se passe s'il y a des retenues dans tous les sens?
Exactement la même chose.
Je pars donc d'en bas à gauche, je prends le 8.
8 + 4 = 12
+ 6 = 18
+ 3 = 21
J'ai donc 21 en tête.
Comme je viens de monter, maintenant je vais changer de colonne.
Je vais donc coller mon 8 à mon 21.
Surtout pas additionner.
Je fais pas 21 + 8 = 29
Mais je colle mon prochain chiffre à celui que j'ai en tête,
donc ça nous fait 218.
J'ai 21 en tête et je colle le 8 derrière
et je pars maintenant de ce 218 pour redescendre et continuer mon addition.
218 + 7 = 225
+ 3 = 228
+ 1 = 229
Mon résultat final est donc de 229.
Il y a eu des retenues, elles se sont intégrées
il n'y a pas d'erreur possible.
Si vous avez des nombres à quatre chiffres, c'est pareil.
On part d'en bas à gauche, on additionne en remontant
ici on colle à notre résultat
on descend, etc..
La méthode de l'ascenseur !
Un dernier exemple très concret pour la route
si jamais vous tombez sur une addition
où les nombres n'ont pas le même nombre de chiffres.
On part d'en bas à gauche
là y'a rien, on voit que le premier c'est la première dizaine de milliers qui est là, le 5.
C'est comme si je faisais 0 + 0 + 0 + 5
J'ai mon 5 en tête, je passe ici et je colle mon 3 au 5, ça nous fait 53.
Je descends : 53 + 0 + 1 + 0 = 54
J'ai 54 en tête, je passe ici donc je colle le 1.
Je vais le noter pour que vous puissiez bien suivre.
Je remonte: +8=549
+1=550
J'en suis donc à 550 en tête.
Je passe ici et colle mon 1 : 5501
je descends : (+2) 5503, (+0) 5503 toujours , (+1) 5504
Ici j'en suis à 5504. Je colle mon 6 : 55046
Je remonte : +9 = 55055
+4 = 55059
+2=55061
Pas d'erreur possible ! C'est forcément juste puisque les retenues se sont intégrées directement.
Si vous vous entraînez un petit peu ça va venir très vite.
Vous allez rapidement gagner en vitesse et vous rendre compte à quel point c'est très simple à faire.
Outre le fait de s'améliorer en calculs mentaux, de pouvoir même bluffer des gens si vous voulez.
Ça muscle en plus le cerveau donc c'est très très bon pour l'esprit.
Par contre, ça veut dire désapprendre la manière qu'on a de calculer aujourd'hui pour les additions :
Où on part de la droite vers la gauche. Là on part de la gauche vers la droite.
Je vous recommande donc vivement d’utiliser la méthode de l’ascenseur pour faire vos additions !
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que le Master class vous a plu.
Ça faisait très longtemps que j'en avais pas fait un sur les maths.
Vous m'en avez demandé plusieurs fois, en voici un !
SI vous voulez me soutenir et soutenir cette vidéo, vous pouvez faire un petit ascenseur avec votre pouce pour en faire un
pouce en l'air !
Vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo puisque je lis, je vous le rappelle, tout les commentaires.
J'y réponds quand je peux mais je lis systématiquement.
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner avant de quitter cette vidéo.
Si ça se trouve, ça fait plusieurs fois que vous regardez des vidéos et vous êtes pas encore abonné.
Pourquoi ? Parce que le Mental Vlog c'est 1 vidéo par jour pendant 1 an !
Du 1er Janvier au 31 Décembre.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 11h.
Ciao !